Zeus became a part of our family because my brother was working with somebody...
...who was breeding Great Danes...
...and ever since I was a little girl, Zeus is very stubborn.
He doesn't do anything unless he wants to.
He is also very laid-back.
He loves everybody.
When he gets excited, it's about ten minutes and he runs around and then he's tired.
His water bowl is the sink.
The only time he's really naughty is, he likes to take food off the counter...
...and he likes to steal the baby's pacifier.
He likes to go on walks around the neighborhood.
He really likes being the center of attention.
Zeus has absolutely changed our family.
He brings so much joy.
He is such a loving, loving dog.
The award for us just really recognizes how special Zeus is.
We get a lot of comments about, "Wow, that's the tallest dog I've ever seen."